hello and welcome to this video playing
the bet okay um yep clock doesn't run
right just run till I already make a
move it's interesting so um they did not
really have a key idea what I wanted to
blame no it just poses some more
interesting okay
I played crew b6 against Luke run Bailey
in a game it was it was real it was a
really interesting game where I
absolutely did not understand how bad my
position was until I really realized how
bad it was one of those games where you
really am yeah at some point feel that
you got outplayed
yeah I'm just making it up yeah I have
no one clean or clear idea of this
opening but you can sometimes just
improvise I wonder I wonder if I can go
45 yeah yeses slightly odd piece
placement so maybe this is not too bad
slightly odd
I mean slightly odd because he's not
really ready to fight for d5 all that
much with the bishop on c3 okay
lots of things on the C file but there
is no tactical I think problem that is
weird I don't see what he's doing with
this pawn now
just drops the pawn yeah here I've got
94 one I mean II for will also win
material but that doesn't look too
convincing a with the open diagonal yeah
94 looks quite good
there is also d5 which I feel could be
interesting
ya know g4 is the most obvious choice
and maybe after night f1 things are not
so clear okay I can play it for ya oh
shoot probably he doesn't have anything
really good yeah
and I gotta take is 3 next no it works
take you three nights
no that doesn't look nice and he does
not have at least I didn't see some
director diem I had this one okay this
is indeed interesting however however if
I take it what is he doing actually if I
take it with the Queen I could take with
a pawn that it's not totally out of the
picture if I take with the Queen though
what is the bishop doing it will move
yeah Bishop g7 Bishop g7 I can take on
c1 and on f3 probably oh my god and
that's uh okay I mean yeah whatever I'm
thinking here also because if I take
with the pond and then doing this now
just for simplicity like this position
unless okay Queen d6 let's not allow
Queen d6 I will go here and then play a
fire unless there is a tactic that I'm
not seeing
I'm strategically just winning he's got
he's got an internship on on g2 okay
here g5 would win even more material
okay I just dropped back ninety five is
a threat
yeah he might try to get some
compensation going here the bishop is
still strong yeah something like this
and then Queen g3m oops oops yeah okay
oh I don't have Queen c7 that is a that
is unfortunate
I wanted to play that yeah okay that
diagonal is scary it is scary
absolutely yeah he wants to take Eve I
can go look everyone now which is at
least a draw okay after no time
twin G - I can grab c3 is 3 plus 2 we
are we have to keep that in mind
oops
three plus two is not a ton of time but
it is enough to avoid complete time
disasters
eleven seconds it's not a lot
and you can always gain the odds second
yeah with the with the increment I would
I would like to put tonight on to a five
but he's got a four which is a good move
and I didn't do it
I've got 15 seconds now which is okay
I'm surprised I think this reasons it
just makes it easier for me to play this
position how do I get to the pawn down I
did not do this or so great hey
technically how do I do this
did you get this pawn going with I
cannot but I'm doing them playing this
with in a weird way him okay let's put
this here and we have probably six or
something okay I can't I can't take it
but now no night see form I can be five
I have no move
I have no move I'm super swamped okay
crank it okay yeah the twins the watch
that wins yeah I don't know there was a
tricky tricky tricky game I mean I
probably made some mistake
after you put this on 23 because I don't
think that should we'll get also I take
Queen b6 and this should be more or less
yeah I mean it should be good
rook f6 is given by the engine that
makes a little sense can I can somehow
cannot prevent that right okay so this
this is what is critical and honestly I
didn't really see my deform yes I can
take III was check but hmm yeah f6 hangs
d6 fangs the engine gives wide enough
compensation as I can believe that
the thing is stuck after this I really
don't know what's best the computer
wants to play to d8 but that cannot be a
mistake I would be surprised to see if
this is really wrong
not everyone and then I went for I am
and that is not given by the computer it
wants to play rook the aides of course
this is a strategically good move but
it's there a real problem with that okay
look f4 it just wants to give me that
pawn okay so I take take king edge one
f5 we have it okay I actually doubt like
when we really look at this that this is
only 0.7 I'm a little bit surprised
yeah because exactly because of h5 and I
now the Evo is going on going
hyah because after age five the bishop
on d2 is really bad
I mean I get g 6d v and I can start to
convert this and the bishop on g2 is
really bad he has to play III to make it
somewhat back into again and somewhat
back into the game and it's not what you
want to do okay in the game c5 of
spelling queen takes e5 is strong yeah I
didn't really see why it shouldn't work
after Bishop g7 Queen C 1 I thought no
just Queen b6 okay yeah essentially
stating that now two pieces are hanging
and here again the two pieces are
hanging out okay but this must be good
as well here what d8 + f5 probably I
just I just played something bad now 95
is correct takes and now just recapture
okay but 94 wins as well take and 96 is
stronger but okay this this should win
also look d6 on Knight to e7 and that is
a really good valid way of defending
this yeah once you see it it kind of
yeah because this Queen comes up here
that looks good okay I went Queen c7
because I spotted I had no time and I
spotted that this is at least a draw so
it was a safer choice Garuda is just
like yeah what are you doing here Queen
d6 completely winning yeah okay
material-wise I am winning and if I get
his six it's actually not that difficult
yeah I think I panicked a bit here yeah
this is I was thinking King edge one and
I thought I have to make
I mean it is a little bit unrealistic
what he did because I mean it's
increment and I'm not going to not going
to lose on time it's remarkable I quit
xe6
sure you know I can take this and the
dough is looks a little bit scary yeah
hear the engine wants me to take I wants
him to take a playbook f7 yeah okay that
that's funny it looks a lot better yeah
quite that would probably be a draw I'm
I'm a bit stuck on the seventh King here
I think it's very likely a draw yeah TM
I'm gonna just a pawn up the conversion
I was surprised that I so got some
issues in this ending probably I just
played it in a bad way
yeah my night maneuvers weren't great I
did that much is clear
yeah yeah I probably should not do this
and I wanted to make some headway a
three is best seems you and why is that
very bad out it's probably okay for
white
I know I am winning not anymore I'm
still winning with the with the game I
wasn't entirely sure and I saw that he
cannot take his six but I was thinking
still if he goes here I wasn't quite
sure what my movements but it's just
King e6 like in the game he cannot take
it in because then the to split pawns
would do the job and then the game we
had essentially the same the same thing
yeah and I'm winning yeah tough game I
probably should have taken on c5 with
the Queen that was the the the fast
simplest thing but I didn't really
calculate it correctly okay guys thanks
for watching